when the Twilight Saga was at its height
it seemed like Taylor Lautner was set to
become one of Hollywood's biggest stars
but then it didn't really turn out that
way here's what may have happened faded
hype Lorna's Twilight co-stars Christian
Stewart and Robert Pattinson were clever
with their careers while still attached
to the franchise they both starred in
other films like Adventureland and Water
for Elephants as a result the duo likely
had an easier time transitioning to
other roles post Twilight Lautner
however had only a bit part in
Valentine's Day to hold him over until
the franchise was over a source told The
Hollywood Reporter it's not easy to move
out of the shadow of a hit like Twilight
but he's still very young
this time for Taylor to become more than
just Jacob box-office bomb Lautner was
the marquee name in 2011 subduction but
the movie didn't do well at all the film
was critically panned and earned a
humiliating four percent on Rotten
Tomatoes that wouldn't be so bad if the
box office numbers were better but the
flick made only twenty eight million
dollars domestically not even breaking
even on his thirty five million dollar
budget an agent told The Hollywood
Reporter his first movie just wasn't
very good and it didn't justify what he
was asking for at the time I mean I'd be
lying if I said there was no pressure
involved but you know I I just try and
stay focused on what I can control too
expensive
Studios just don't think Lautner is
worth the money he asks for a source
told vulture that Lautner's talent
agency did a brilliant job of convincing
Hollywood that he's a next big movie
star but didn't convince audiences of
the same Lautner demanded five million
dollars for abduction when that bombed
Studios could no longer justified a 7.5
million dollars he asked for to star in
Stretch Armstrong and the whopping ten
million dollars to star in the retelling
of the biblical David and Goliath both
movies were shelved indefinitely four
years after abduction traces was
Lautner's second attempt at a leading
role unfortunately the film never even
got a USC a trick or a lease and the
reviews from those who actually did see
it were not good the ridiculous six
Lautner seems to have gotten in tight
with Adam Sandler landing a bit part and
grownups too and the supporting role in
the Netflix film the ridiculous six and
fortunately the ridiculous six not only
scored a whopping zero
sent on Rotten Tomatoes but also happen
to stir up a lot of controversy over
perceived racist jokes Lautner would
probably do well to just leave that one
up his resume passion project in 2016
Lautner took on the film run the tide an
indie drama with no budget and no big
studio backing it couldn't have been
further from his Twilight roots or his
attempts at becoming an action hero
Lautner described the film in a metro
interview as a passion project for
everyone involved
unfortunately reviews were dismal the
a/v Club labeled a bargain-basement
schmaltz to Branly folks he even for
Sundance and the young folks claimed the
emotion felt for Stan it lacked
authenticity the review even zero didn't
specifically Alana's performance saying
that it just isn't very believable as
much as he tries to be is it any
surprise that Lautner seemed to take a
sabbatical after this taking his time
Lautner has admitted that he'll be
pickier about the roles he chooses
moving forward when asked by ABC News if
he was worried about being pigeon-holed
by his twilight role Lautner said it's
kind of why I want to choose things that
are different while he considers his
career's direction lawton is really not
in any hurry to get back on a movie set
he told Reuters in November 2016 for me
the biggest thing is just surrounding
myself with people that I love just
spending time it doesn't matter what I'm
doing as long as I'm with my friends or
my family what he did and what I'm not
working you know playing sports with my
buddies watching The Bachelor focused on
love Lautner and Billy Lord met on the
set of scream queens and their on-screen
romance spilled over into real life
according to people Lord and Lautner's
rumored relationship began in December
2016 Lorde's uncle Todd Fisher said the
relationship was as serious as it was
adorable
telling E news he stepped up and acted
like a husband would act not that that's
what's going on but it's just an amazing
support system for her and I'm glad he's
in her life
however by July 2017 Lord and Lautner
were over as a couple is it possible
that Lautner had pressed the pause
button on acting for this romance work
reunion one of the brightest spots in
Lautner's career has been the gamble he
took for placing Andy samberg's
character on the BBC comedy kuku he was
playing completely against type but he
apparently
nailed it according to the Telegraph
Lautner was very good indeed
series co-star Greg Davies also had
nothing but praise for Lautner hinting
to Metro in November 2017 that they may
work together in the future he said it's
an unlikely friendship but doing two
more series next year I get on really
well with them
it's a thoroughly decent chap granted
that's not a confirmation that Lautner
is on board but it sure seems like he's
got an open invitation and a critically
lauded Avenue to pursue should he choose
to accept it thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]